hey guys so I wanted to chime in on this
Ben Affleck Sam Harris Bill Maher
episode from real time about ten days
ago we know the word racist was used
that is what Ben Affleck said of Sam
Harris and Bill Maher or at least their
views he was at least calling their
views races but I think it was kind of
gone that racist at the same time and I
wanted to chime in on this because I
think the media fallout both in the
mainstream media and online media has
been really terrible it's been a lot of
selectively editing clips and
manipulating the quotes and really
implying things that were said that
weren't quite said I also think when you
throw the word racist out there as it
was thrown out so quickly in this clip
that then it really just destroys any
honest conversation and really it just
makes a whole big freakin mess so I want
to make three quick points and then
we're going to show the entire thing and
I'm going to chime in and I know that
could be 10 or 12 minutes of internet
time which is a lot but I think we can
do it but I want to make three quick
points just at the top so number one
normally on real time when they do this
when the guest comes in which is where
Sam came in and sat on the same side of
the table as Billy it's really for a
one-on-one and occasionally the people
on the panel which is the previous
segment where they all go back and forth
occasionally they'll try and maybe ask a
question or comment or something but
that's not what happened here a Ben
Affleck immediately attacked so I do
think there was some premeditated
something or other on behalf of Ben so
that's just number one I think it's
important to say because in the
construct of a show that was not how I
think it was supposed to go and I think
that adds a little bit of just sort of
the TV what's actually going on behind
the scenes I think it's important to
understand that um number two if Ben
Affleck had not said racist nobody would
be talking about this if the
conversation had gone exactly the same
but Ben Affleck hadn't thrown out racist
nobody would be saying this but all
media loves you also want to raise this
tiger automatically racist and then
people defend one side and the other
side and we just lose any real ability
to happen on this conversation that
that's number two and number three
beyond anything else and beyond anything
else that I say in this video or that
you're going to see in this video we
have freedom of speech in this country
and everyone needs to calm down because
I think all of the people on that panel
then Sam bill everybody they do believe
in freedom of speech and I think what's
happening here
in the in the post-mortem of this is
that everyone's attacking everybody and
does don't want them to say what their
feelings are but that is the most
American thing that you can possibly do
and I think it's important that we all
just take a little bit of a step back
all right so that being said we're going
to show you the full thing here because
I think a lot of the selective editing
of what I've seen has been part of the
problems we're going to show you the
full thing and I'm just going to chime
in as we go along here's real time here
we go so the other thing we want to talk
about of course is that you and I have
been trying to make the case I think I
have anyway that liberals need to stand
up for liberal principles this is what I
said on last week's show obviously I got
a lot of hate for it but all I'm saying
is that liberal principles like freedom
of speech freedom to practice any
religion you want without fear of
violence freedom to leave a religion
equality for women equality for
minorities including homosexuals these
are liberal principles that liberals
applaud for but then when you say in the
Muslim world this is what's lacking then
they get upset yeah yeah well liberals
have really failed on the topic of
theocracy they'll criticize white
theocracy it'll criticize Christians
they'll still get agitated over the
abortion clinic bombing that happened in
1984 but when when you want to talk
about the treatment of women and
homosexuals and freethinkers and and
public intellectuals in the Muslim world
I would argue that liberals have failed
us and the crucial point of confusion
yeah thank you my god you're here okay
so that's just the beginning that's just
the beginning right and what is
interesting is they're talking with the
failures of liberals not the failure of
the Islamic world or Muslims or anything
like that they're talking with a failure
of liberals and I think their point is
well-taken because liberals constantly
they constantly attack we constantly
attacked Christian anything about Tim
Tim Tebow or the duck dynasty guys and
there's this constant conflation between
just a crazy extremists and I'm not even
content even extremists constant
conflation between the people and the
extremists right the regular people in
the extremists and that's so there he's
pointing fault of the liberal
that we liberals who should be open to
all ideas need to also be critical of
all ideas and I think Sam is making that
distinction the clip ended there we've
been already ready to jump in with some
anger so the crucial point of confusion
is that that we have been sold this meme
of Islamophobia where every criticism of
the doctrine of Islam gets conflated
with bigotry toward Muslims as people
right that is it's intellectually
ridiculous okay I think that's a very
fair point by Sam if you're allowed to
attack Christians right and not claim
that you hate all Christians or you're
Christian of phobic is that word
something like that uh then you should
be allowed to do with every religion
Judaism included every religion Buddhism
whatever you want should be included now
here's where it starts to derail a
little bit oh hold on the person who
understands the officially codified
doctrine of Islam you're on a trip or
what oh you won't say what this is I
think any actually well-educated on this
time I'm asking you I mean you're saying
if I criticize that you're saying that
Islamophobia is not a real thing okay
then that is completely not what he said
he didn't say Islamophobia is not a
thing
he said we should be able to be critical
of the bad ideas or the bad people right
and not that they're Islamophobia does
not exist he didn't say that at all and
actually he's going to further clarify
that later now here's a really
interesting part of this I'm going to
show you a quick piece from Bill Maher
here we go that if you're critical of
something what's not a real thing when
we do it but well what not it really is
okay so this is not a great line by Bill
his intention I think makes sense he's
saying we are the people that are okay
with everyone's ideas so it's not bad
when we do it but I can absolutely see
conservatives and rational people saying
that's not acceptable and everyone needs
to be held to account for their words so
I think this is a little dicey on Bill's
part but I don't think it's it's that
terrible okay let's go ahead I'm not
denying that that certain people are
bigoted against Muslims as people that
right and that's a problem big of you
okay so Sam is absolutely saying that
yes some people are bigoted towards
Muslims we all know this this is
absolutely obvious he is acknowledging
what Ben is saying then then comes back
with the smug well that's big of you
because Ben is or
ready to fight no matter what Sam said
but why don't we have to go about this
it's gross it's racist
it's not it's but it's so nice oh it's
like saying go so Nate you're shifty Jew
you're not let me not we are saying you
guys are saying if you want to be
liberals believe in liberal principles
right freedom speech like mom you know
we are endowed by our forefathers in a
little bowl a strike all men are created
oh ok so here's the big moment of this
entire thing this is where he says your
idea is a racist basically you're racist
and then bill is saying no you're not
listening to us we are making the
distinction between most people and and
the extremists I think that is extremely
clear Ben just keeps taking this idea
that he wants to believe that they're
saying and keep pushing the idea okay so
let's continue
Ben we have to be able to criticize bad
ideas and of course we didn't own the
rule doesn't work okay cuz bad but is
why when is the mother lode of bad ideas
jeez okay so this is this is kind of a
bad line by Sam now he makes a
distinction of saying right now when
he's saying Islam is the mother lode of
bad ideas but yes absolutely all the
books have crazy stuff in the Old
Testament New Testament Koran everything
does he's saying that right now I think
what I think what he's trying to say is
that right now the Koran has more ideas
that are being pushed by bad people but
I think this is a dicey line and I can
understand why some people would be
upset by it I think he's talking about
not the book itself that the book itself
as a whole is necessarily worse than any
other three but that in practice some
people are manipulating it or using it
in a way that people aren't using the
other book I think that could be a
perfectly fine argument but again I
think this is a bit of a dicey line by
since we have it we have like climb out
of me it is ugly apostasy it is basic
let me unpack intolerance let me look
let me unpack or not for intolerance
more tonight okay bill makes a great
point here yes we should be tolerant but
not for in tolerance right bill and
Sam's repeatedly have said right now
that it is not all Muslims they keep
saying that I don't know how much more
they can say the picture you're painting
is to some extent true but is hugely
incomplete it is
true that plenty of fanatics and jihadis
are Muslim but the people who are
standing up to them Malala Muhammad Ali
Dada can in Iran in prison for nine
years speaking up for Christians a
friend that I had in Pakistan who was
shot this year Rashid Rehman for
defending people accused for posture all
right good point by new Krista there is
a lot of good people out there we
probably should be paying more attention
to them
and I don't think that's against
anything that either bill or Sam have
said so far or how about more than a
billion people those are no fanatical
who don't go to the wait a second don't
like any of the things they say almost
is the only way when area like not wait
a great your settings and you painting a
pet the whole group religion without no
what no then that's exactly not what
they said they aren't taking the broad
brush they are making the distinction
between most people and the extremists I
don't know how many times they can
possibly say it although they're gonna
keep saying let's get down to who has
the right answer here a billion people
you say all these billion people don't
hold any of those in rec five don't hold
these pernicious beliefs no I wouldn't
well they don't that's just not true Ben
that's just not a true can I can I use
me Freddy no I think it brings down the
idea
you haven't really I think you're trying
to say that these few people that's all
the problem is these few bad apples the
idea that someone should be killed if
they leave but the horrible that's it
wait wait that is wait you're saying
that idea that someone should be killed
if they leave the Islamic religion is
just a few bad apples the people who
would actually believe in an act that
you murder somebody if they have Islam
is not the majority of Muslims at all
okay
again Ben that is not what they said
they did not say the majority of Muslims
believe that you should kill people for
leaving the religion that's precisely
the opposite of what they say let me let
me break this down right we have a
perception as you as you say we have 1.5
1.6 billion Muslims now like an Biggest
Loser in the world a quarter well man
let me let me unpack actually unpack
this for you please do out and we have
air pack just imagine some concentric
circles here you have at the center you
have jihadists these are people who wake
up in the morning wanting to kill
apostates wanting to
die trying they believe in paradise they
horrible Valley Buddha and martyrdom
outside of them we have Islamists these
are these are people who are just as
convinced of martyrdom and paradise and
and wanting to to voice their religion
on the rest of humanity but they want to
work within the system they're not going
to blow themselves up on a bus they want
to change governments they want to use
democracy against itself that it that
those two circles arguably are 20% of
the Muslim world okay this is this is
not what amazing research a bunch of
poll results that we can talk about okay
I don't know the polls that Sam is
referring to on the 20% but he strikes
me as an honest person and I bet you
he'd be willing to post those polls so I
think we have to at least go with that
since Ben is just yelling things at this
point I think we have to at least
believe the basic idea of what Sam
saying I think I'm not I can't swear to
the balls cuz I haven't seen 78% of
British Muslims think that the Danish
cartoonist should have been prosecuted
78% so I'm being conservative when I
roll this back to 20% but outside of
that circle you have conservative
Muslims who can can write what can
honestly look at Isis and say that that
does not represent us were horrified by
that but they hold views about human
rights and about women about homosexuals
that are deeply troubling so so these
are not Islamists or not jihadis
but they but they both those abusers but
and but they also keep women and
homosexuals immiseration in these
cultures and we have to empower the true
reformers in the Muslim world to to
change it okay I think this is a great
line by Sam he's making the distinction
that Ben keeps asking for between the
extremists and the average person any
saying we have to empower moderates this
is what liberals and people on the Left
say all the time and we have to empower
the people who believe in all the things
such as equal rights for gay people and
minorities and women we have do these
are the people that we have to empower
I'm pretty sure everybody agrees on and
what I was lying about the length of my
doctrine talk and behavior is not going
to do that law the great survive
the Great Divide is not the plane or
Islam and the rest
it's rather between the fundamentalists
and the moderates in each faith but
we're mislead to think that the
fundamentalists are the fringe okay we
have jihad jihadis yes I'm a
conservative and by the way there's a
million just people there saying that
the that the strongest voices are coming
from those who are jihadists and
extremists and answer that is a bigger
piece of the pie than we often think is
true there's no question ok so having
said that and if you even if that is
true statistically or otherwise the key
thing to recognize that I don't think is
part of the argument but I think should
be is that there are voices that are
often time raised in opposition to these
jihadists yeah into this extreme max but
guess what they don't get covered they
don't get exposed and they're not given
the same well they've won same level of
platform that we see ok so Nick Kristof
and Michael Steele are both making the
same point that there are all these
moderates and we need to pay more
attention to them and the media needs to
pay more attention to them we've tried
to cover these people on my show I think
part of the reason that they don't get
covered is because it would also under
earth sort of our kind of evil alliances
like with Saudi Arabia where they're
teaching this crazy brand of Wahhabism
and women can't drive and can't vote
well they're also one of our big allies
so we were to talk about all the bad
things and the good people fighting the
bad things in Saudi Arabia
it would also expose some of the
hypocrisy of America and unfortunately
our media is very much in bed with our
political establishment so that doesn't
happen but I'm pretty sure everybody
agrees or most rational people would
agree with everything that Nick Kristof
and Michael Steele just one reason they
don't get exposed is because they were
afraid to speak out baby that's the old
oh it's eat because it's the only
religion that acts like the Mafia that
will [ __ ] kill you that you say the
wrong thing and I draw the wrong picture
or write the wrong body okay that's very
politically incorrect Bill Maher used to
host a show called politically incorrect
and it may make people uncomfortable to
hear that but that is true if I'm right
now drew a picture of Jesus nobody would
care I drew a picture of the Jewish god
yahwah right or
his name is nobody would care if I drew
a picture Mohammad people would care and
I'd be getting death threats that's just
a fact it is uncomfortable and it's
unfortunate and again this goes to why
we have to strengthen moderate in the
community so I know that part makes
people uncomfortable it makes it seem
like bill somehow hates Islam more but
he's just stating a fact
there's a reason why I on Hirsi Ali
needs bodyguards 24/7 that element of
fear as well but you also have other
braver souls out there who do speak out
and who'd like you are risking their
life like that like the the Muslim
clerics and others and from Australia to
to Europe to the United States just
recently publicly put their names on
paper declare declaring their opposition
to what Isis and others are doing so
there are those voices but where was the
coverage where was where was that story
to sort of operate a different paper
okay again very fair point by Michael
Steele we need to cover these people
more that will allow them to be
strengthened I think that's the point
that bills making I think that's the
point that Sam is making and I think
that's the point that most rational
people would make what is your soul what
is your abs no just academic dissolute I
don't know the sutures drink what we
killed more Muslims and they've killed
us by an awful lot we've been aided more
I am NOT remarkable I was an awful lot
yet somehow we're exempting things
because they're not really reflection of
a I don't believe in we did by accident
that's why we invaded Iraq and put
forward way of Europe we're not
convincing anyone yes we have killed
tons of Muslims we have done terrible
things often I think trying to do the
right thing about has done terrible
things that we've propped up dictators
and you know what Muslims had killed
tons of Muslims too they're doing it
right now most of what's happening right
now is Muslims killing Muslims us
killing them all so we're sort of
helping the regimes that are in place
try to stay in power so I guess it is
that's an extremely complicated
geopolitical conversation but that's
sort of a separate issue than what we're
talking about here but I'm telling you
that I disagree with what you don't I
know any we're obviously not good
you don't understand why are you no are
you no black people Lenalee show no no
it's not it's based on facts I can show
you a Pew poll of Egyptians they are not
outliers in the Muslim world let's say
like 90 percent of them believe death is
the appropriate response to leaving the
religion if 90 percent of Brazilians
thought that death was the appropriate
response to leaving Catholicism you
would think it was a bigger deal okay
bill totally put Ben in his place right
there he wasn't saying all black people
it's all the same
he was absolutely this entire video has
been about making that distinction now
you can argue whether making that there
being fair in making that distinction
but that's what this whole thing has
been about and Ben keeps trying to frame
it as they're saying this is about all
Muslims which is clearly at this point
just absolutely not what they're saying
I would think it's a big deal no matter
what okay but that's but what we do is
say it's all Brazilian so I wouldn't say
well Ted by and hid by god damn these
gays are trying to eat each other again
Ben I don't think you're listening
because that is a hundred percent not
what they said rude eat it let me just
give you what you want there are
hundreds of millions of Muslims who are
nominal Muslims who don't take the faith
seriously who don't want to kill
apostates who are horrified by Isis and
we need to defend these people prop them
up and let them rejoice Isis couldn't
fill a double-a ballpark in Charleston
West Virginia and you're making a career
I don't know no okay right there now Sam
just hands Ben exactly what he's asking
for he's saying there are hundreds of
millions of Muslims who are good people
everyone knows that that is just so
painfully obvious everyone knows that
and then again now you're making a
career out of Isis actually I don't know
that until the last month or so Sam
Harris ever talked about Isis he had a
career before that so it's just not it's
just not Ben is just taking talking
points he's taking sort of the stuff
that gets everybody buzzing in the media
and he just keeps attacking and he's
doing the exact reverse he's doing the
type of moral equivalence that people
claim Fox News does and that's exactly
what Ben is doing here and it is not
what Sam is not just Isis ideology Honus
is global is a phenomenon as well I
think that's the opposite there is those
things there's Isis there's global
jihadist the question is the degree to
which you're willing to say
because I've witnessed this behavior
which we all object to on the part of
these people I'm willing to flatly
condemn those of you I don't know any
late again been one more time oh that is
not what they were doing are you getting
the theme here no this is not any people
it's ideas and not a man and people who
believe in those ideas people believe
based on reality bags we're not making
it up that there is that in the Muslim
world
it is mainstream belief but this may
catch a caricature of Indonesia of
Malaysia a waiter in much of the world
and this does have the tinge a little
bit of the way white racists talk about
African Americans and define blacks okay
so I think this is a good point by now
Christoph look we both there's a bunch
of white non Muslims on this panel
debating this so could there be some
inherent racism or in some inherent
separation or something like that could
that exist in this conversation since
none of the people that you're talking
about are on the panel I think that is a
fair argument often on my show you know
we book sometimes a couple weeks before
so occasionally we've done a Ferguson
segment let's say and I didn't have a
black person on or and people get angry
at me but I booked way in event I don't
know how they booked the show I don't
know that bill intended this to become
some giant conversation I think
originally it was really supposed to be
more so about sam Harris's book and that
kind of thing so this is sort of changed
but I think Nick is making a fair point
generally that you have people that this
isn't really fully about those trying to
make this about the Liberals and how
liberals should act but there when
they're talking all about Muslims and
then you don't have a Muslim on the
panel I think that is a fair point by
what you're saying is recognize they're
a minority we shouldn't make we
shouldn't we shouldn't criticize that
much of a minority a second because
religion exactly but there but you're
treating them like a minority
I mean if Filipinos were capturing
teenagers and sending them into white
slavery we would criticize that we
wouldn't say well there's other people
who are doing it not the Philippines you
know I mean what if potatoes are walking
dinner's on the street from you would
have nothing to do with that so there
are different things crazy facial sorry
I think let's let's talk at we've
mentioned Isis but to talk about that
okay so that was the entire segment it
ends again with then making a comparison
that is completely not the comparison
that they were making okay so I just
want to add a couple things on to the
end of this you know look again first
off it had the word racist not been used
people would have talked about this for
a day or two and then that would have
been it when been immediately throws the
word racist in in a segment that I don't
know that he was even supposed to really
be part of that's what gets the media
crazy and then that's what gets the team
and the the groupthink on both sides
going and everybody attacking each other
so I think you can have an honest
discussion I listen I get Ben's bigger
point I get his bigger point but
immediately attacking them as racists
and saying that their views are not
valid is not fair and that's not what
they were doing to him um I think the
part that's that's hitting me more about
this is what Bill is saying that
liberals are not supposed to be tolerant
of intolerance we have to stand up for
liberal principles and I absolutely
believe that and yes that doesn't not
acknowledge that we've done bad things
you know it somehow people are trying to
paint this like Bill is somehow now a
neocon wants to tell the whole world
what to do he is first off did you see
Religulous he hates all religions he
took the big three down pretty equally
in his documentary religious so he's
done that he also talks all the time
about how we have such a bloated
military and why do we have 30,000
troops in Germany and why are we in all
these places and and I think he's more
of a libertarian at heart
moreover Rand Paul almost an
isolationist then then somehow that bill
is a racist who wants American foreign
policy be dictated by Christian
principles across the world so I think
that that's just nuts um the other the
other part of this is um listen I'm not
Muslim
so again to NIC Christoph's point if you
have a bunch of non Muslim people
talking about being Muslim and what the
community the worldwide community of
Muslim people think and there's some
twine in it that doesn't totally ring
true I think that is perfectly fair
point I can just analyze this
I can see it and I think that we there
could there was an opportunity here for
a much better conversation than what was
had and then unfortunately as I said at
the beginning then we watched a
gajillion people in mainstream media and
online media take quotes for their own
purposes and manipulated I hope you see
that it's not what I did here I've tried
to analyze what was actually said and I
think we can go from here and have an
interesting discussion on how to make
the distinction between extremists and
regular people in all groups of course
of course and maybe the left and
liberals can learn a little something
here and maybe the Atheist community can
learn a little something about tolerance
but I think if we can all agree on one
thing it's that Ben Affleck as Batman
will not be nearly as good as Michael
key